i don't i don't share that much
you guys are my friends but do you guys
really know me like how close are we
really
do you know what i mean like me and fire
we went to iceland
and i told him straight up i was like
bro i don't really open up a hundred
percent with people i don't tell them
everything i don't let them in a hundred
percent because i know that once
someone's in a hundred percent
like it's just it's too much you know
people are always going to let you down
fellas you gotta stop replacing allah
with
girls with women stop
using women as that placeholder
to correct all of your emotional
feelings your heart your
your love your this i'm not saying don't
love a woman and don't
don't be you know don't make them feel
good and don't be emotionally connected
to them but what i'm saying is
that little voice in your in your head
that little feminine energy that you got
because obviously as men we still got
that that tells you you know
i need this thing this this this place
of contact that i can collect my love
that i could just pour my heart out that
i could just share everything about my
day
that i could just give my soul to fully
why are you doing that to your women
when
your woman when women can't even take
that the right way when they don't even
know how to handle that bro
you might scare her off you might at the
end of the day look
women do that to us to men they vent to
you they come home they tell you oh
this is what happened at work see they
do this because at the end of it
they feel that relief they feel good
they feel like okay i just let i just
discharged all this energy that i had
and they feel more connected to you but
it's not the same way with with women
fellas if you go to your woman
and you tell her about this you vent you
do this bro it's not the same
what you should be doing is do this to
the most high to allah to the source
you should be on the prayer mat
on your knees hearing i don't care if
you're crying if you're breaking down
repenting venting showing all your
frustrations sharing everything
crying for help crying for guidance
crying for the blessings of allah
and it's like at the end of the day this
is the point
allah is the point of contact that you
need to be letting all of this out on
because at the end of the day i
guarantee you that feeling that a woman
has when she's done venting to her man
is going to be the feeling that you have
when you're done opening up to allah
on the name the salah and when you've
done that and when you've done that
you can truly feel good and non-needy
and emotionally like i need to give this
to my woman
when you talk to her you're going to go
to her you're going to be more grounded
you're going to be more cool you're
going to be more chill
and she'll sense that from you you know
what i mean and it's like
part of it knows damn like why can't why
can't i be that but it's like trust me
like women women say that but they don't
want that so at the end of the day
put allah first make allah the thing
that
women look to you as obviously women
should look to allah before they're mad
but you guys get what i'm what i'm
saying for the sake of scenario
the thing that women need you as to be
that rock to be that thing that
they can be a storm around you got to
look at allah to be that
so that you can be yourself and fully
let go emotionally around
yeah and there's nothing wrong with that
because allah tells you time and time
again my slave come to me repent to me
pour your heart out to me share
everything with me
so why don't you start having that that
scenario because girls are really good
at that man girls have
they have diaries bro they got the
sisterhood they got the friends
on speed dial they're bro they know that
we're open
energy systems like angel always
preachers and they know that they can
discharge any time
but as men we we constantly try to
repress ourselves because like
okay yeah i'll admit it bro no other man
wants to hear your issues we're not like
girls
but it's like allah is always there 24
7. here's the thing next you wanna you
wanna hit up your homies it's 5am
and you're like damn bro they're asleep
i know you guys know that feeling you
can relate to that and you're like damn
how could i hit them up if they're
they're catching some sleep oh i gotta
wait till tomorrow so you cry yourself
to sleep or
i don't know bro some guys are hell
emotional but it's like allah is open
it's 5 a.m fajr is an hour away you
could pray tahjid you could do the night
prayer
and you could pray to allah allah is
never going to close his doors for you
so why don't you use that
if they're not with you
bro like it it it destroys you man like
i've been through it twice i've been
through
two times where i was like completely
just hurt bro
one time was cheated on the other time
was just
completely out of nowhere it just
completely stripped away so it was like
for me
to give so much than to have it all just
broken apart it's like
i don't know if it's just me i don't
know if it's just because i'm hurt but
like a part of me
doesn't want to give everything
[Music]
to one person because i know how
imperfect
yeah we are as humans on hell
habibi i love you for the sake of allah
man i love you thank you
um think about it these were non-muslim
women these are non-muslim women and
even you know
you know you know my story and stuff she
even though she was muslim by name like
come on like in the actions and stuff
she wasn't really there and uh
we both have very similar experiences
unfortunately but think about it
you know what's better than a woman not
cheating on you
for your sake a woman not cheating on
you for the sake of allah
because there are reasons for you might
die eventually for reasons for allah
if she's at that point you might as well
just leave her like what the hell is the
point of being with her
at that point she doesn't have that love
for her stand that's why the fossil is
in them said the best
traits to look for in a spouse
regardless is good character
and good religion but when they have the
deen
when they have islam when you can just
when you look at them
and you're like this person loves allah
the way i love allah
they love islam the way i love islam and
it's better
that the reason they won't do anything
to harm me is because of allah
because they know they'll be accountable
because if they were to cheat on me
harm me neglect me abuse me manipulate
me
and they don't believe in allah they're
free to do that if they really want to
until i walk away
but if they believe in allah they know
them well that they're going to be
punished for that
and even if it doesn't work out at least
they'll end respectfully
on a good note
myself bro i still have temptations i
still have urges
and anytime these urges start coming in
bro i started peeing in my head
allahu akbar allahu akbar and bro like i
will
i will say it louder and louder and
louder each time in my head and if i
gotta say it verbally i'll say it
verbally
because every time i say it it's not
only enforcing
the fact that god is greater but it's
cancelling out everything that's going
on in my head because you can't have
two things you can't have something
negative and something positive going on
in your head at once
so if if you have this negative thing
coming in if you have this
um this temptation this urge is craving
and then you start putting this positive
thing and it starts getting so great
bro you can't have the negative thing in
there you can't be thinking it
if you're just giving all your attention
all your energy to
the almighty and you're asking for
strength
you are literally you're submitting
yourself
and saying you know what i can't do this
i can't do this by myself i need you
i need you and when you do that but like
you're getting all the strength you need
and
that's what's going to ultimately keep
you on the straight path that's what's
going to free you
from pornography assalamu
welcome back to t3m for those of y'all
have been tuning in
thank you for doing that your support
means a lot for those of you that are
new to our channel
remember to hit subscribe we are a new
up and coming channel trying to bring
current muslim issues
talk about some things that people are
not too comfortable with
not always politically correct but our
thoughts are genuine and unfiltered
nonetheless
today we are joined with the man the
myth
the legend peter griffin
peter griffin yo angel who did you say
he looks like
he was like an african mohammed hijab
100
man we are joined with even more the
time traveler muhammad
salaam alaikum
how are you my bros alhamdulillah 1000
the time traveler yeah right at the
beginning i conflated youtube
i thought you were him and then i
because i read your name and i'm like
i always thought it was imam but maybe
maybe not so
yeah it's similar here comes from i was
inspired by yo so
real quick is that your dad or what
because
i mean like i play the i play the role
of imam mura's son
on the internet so yeah but it's like a
completely different person
like i could explain like where that all
came from yeah
okay all right let me just dive in all
right so it started
with christian prince you know do you
guys know who christian prince is
no he's just this uh anti-islam youtuber
so like
he was reading like some commentary on
like an islamic text
and it said which basically means he
once said
and then he like completely conflated it
and said that it was an imam
of islam that was saying that so he said
your imam murad is the one who said it
so he conflated it so like
basically and then there's this guy
so this is like from free response i'm
sorry i'm jumping around like everywhere
but like now go ahead bro go ahead
it was on fareed response's channel so
he he started this
he basically made this whole character
imam mura and then he put like a peter
griffin like
peter griffin with the whole thing on
and then there was a guy
who started putting that as his profile
picture and then like
yeah he started coming to me making
jokes
and then i was like let me just join him
like i was the second person who joined
and now if you look on youtube there's
other roles like abu mura
and like all these other accounts that
came from that so like
that basically is just an insult to
christian prince
and his academic integrity
i guess right or this integrity yeah
yeah the lack of that yeah so that's
where it came from
that's the kind of luck i actually
didn't know that i mean i knew about
imamura and farid
he has like 107 lies from christian
prince
like i have 107 videos talking about his
life i put it all together if you've
ever visited my channel
or i put it like i i put it all together
and it was actually like two hours long
i was not expecting it to be that long
and like i get christian prince fans in
my comments and they're like you are
afraid to debate cp's
because like they always want you to go
they always want you to go on christian
prince's
channel and try to debate because like
he makes money off of that and it's like
their entertainment so they're not
really looking for any answers
yeah and this is the issue when people
what was that
i could see that yeah a lot of bro
there's a lot of money in hating islam
like david wood has a paper yeah it
makes a lot of money
right yeah same with all these other
david wood was like the first anti-islam
person that i came across
yeah yeah and i was like what's the
other dude christian prince
christian
yeah i saw his video on you like you saw
the whole thing
i didn't really watch it because like
i'm like i really want to see what he
has to say but i don't want to give him
a view and like
yeah yeah i have not watched it at all
to me
i didn't watch it but like it's it's
weird it's like they're trying to stop
people from converting to islam like
every time somebody converts
islam every time someone converts this
slime they make a video so like
like any time i search up your convert
story his is like right under it like
like criticizing charlie it's done
i saw i saw the first five minutes bro i
saw the i'm sorry this guy's an actual
idiot i saw the first five minutes
he's no i'm sorry i i don't mean
anything
don't apologize bro he he he went to the
extent
of denying yeah media mass manipulation
and the fact that if media runs with a
story that's false everyone will believe
it and think it's true
there are scholarly articles about it
there are statistics there's works done
on it
and he went to the extent of denying it
because angel made a point that
he thought islam was this terroristic
religion because that's the fox news
narrative
many people many people can testify to
that there's works on it
he as soon as angel said that he started
laughing and i'm like you're gonna deny
mass media manipulation that's why i say
he's an idiot because
it's it's basically the um he chooses
the narrative
and he runs with it essentially that's
what you know everyone does but
it's basically what what these people
operate off of is something called the
sharpshooter fallacy right you guys know
like if you ever been like art
you know if you went to a shooting range
right or um arching or anything like
that are
is it arching or archery archery
yeah yeah archery with the bow and arrow
yeah yeah thank you archery
um you know you know they have the
bullseye you try and hit in the middle
the sharpshooter fallacy is there's no
bullseye
you shoot the wall and then you draw the
bullseye around the bullet hole you made
right that's essentially what they're
doing they pick the narrative
and then they draw everything around it
they say see i was completely right i
hit it on the spot
that's essentially you know what these
people do and it's uh
as a brother said a lack of academic
integrity um this is why when he went
and you know he got basically uh jumped
by muhammad hijab on the uh
the adam saleh podcast he didn't have
any answers
and he took off his headphones and
started acting like a baby that's why
david wood
when he when he went to get muhammad
hijab muhammad hijab had the um
the privilege of saying you know 20
years of dissing
islam and researching islam and all of
his arguments were dismissed in four
minutes
yep satisfying that that's i love that
debate
so much bro yeah right at the end of the
debate
when um i didn't watch the whole thing i
saw little snippets but i love the
the part where um hijab he was going in
and he was basically done he had like
two minutes left he's i'm just going to
recite the quran for y'all yeah said
you can add this time to david wood yeah
they give it
i watched the positive profit video bro
he had a whole thing he was like
i watched most of it and he there was at
the part where he was like
oh how are you guys going to let a man
who can't even pronounce
catholicism come and talk about islam
and all that oh yeah
because i say catholicism yeah and i'm
like bro how is that even a valid point
bro tomato tomato but anyway if you want
to disregard that yeah then these fools
talk about in the comments how
we're just going to wait till next week
when he says oh i'm going to be buddhist
or another week where he's like oh i'm
going to be a jew and it's like
bro come on man you guys like they
picked the narrative just like rami said
and they're finding proof to just
support that even if it's basis
bro i'm gonna lay it out real clear
all right number one if he had a true
intention to help
he would have reached out to me
personally he wouldn't have
made any video he would have reached out
to me personally and had an
actual talk not a debate a talk
number two if he wants to debate bro
he's already
been debated and he's been destroyed in
that debate yeah so like it makes no
sense
for me or anyone else to debate him and
number three
i don't debate i use my hands i use my
legs i use my body like bro
if you want to get to that level we can
fight like i have no
no animosity towards you bro but like if
you want to come at me
sideways we can handle it like men
simple as that bro yeah
have you seen uh apostate prophet versus
daniel hakikachu
i heard it was good i heard it was
really it was it was really good he got
slaughtered on about uh sharia law it
was it was crazy he was
he even cussed he dropped the f-bomb if
you didn't watch the
highlights someone's gonna take
someone's gonna take what you said out
of context you got slaughtered by sharia
law
damn bro yeah they will they will but
like he got
roasted so bad like he was talking about
slavery and islam and like
daniel was just proving every point like
justifying
every single thing like logically like
this man was slouching in his chair like
he wasn't expecting like this much of a
beating it was crazy so like when he
noticed that daniel was bringing like
studies
after study after study he started
interrupting and cussing and all this
stuff
it was good i definitely recommend you
should watch it and try to get him on
the podcast too daniel
he's very good we're gonna reach out to
him that's a shame dude
yeah i mean bro
again i want to say like i have no
animosity towards anymore anyone else
bro cause like
all these people on here they're
reacting
with emotion it's like bro i have
nothing to react
to you are not doing anything to me
personally
you're trying to but it's not doing
anything to me
now if you like mess with my family then
it's a different story
yeah you know but like bro it's youtube
it's youtube bro and again like i said
if you wanted to help
he could reach out to people versus
making a video
just for views and for money yeah and
you know it's silly bro
i find it funny because even using the
the uh the phrase want to help
the hell is he helping with he doesn't
he doesn't have a solid way of life
he doesn't have objective truth he
doesn't even know what's good or bad how
the hell is he going to help
yeah he doesn't he doesn't even know how
morality works he was saying that there
was a
different option besides objective and
subjective morality like
he was just like because he knows what
he he knows he knew where he was gonna
go right i think he's
not i don't think he's smart but he's
he's definitely not that dumb he knows
where it's going to go that's why i have
to say there's a third option that i'm
not going to mention for
you know undisclosed reasons um but bro
like help in what sense
you don't you don't know what good is
you don't know what bad is you don't
know what moral and moral
terms mean they mean nothing to you he
has like
his idea of morality is just as
productive as my
love for the taste of oranges that's how
productive it is
like it's yeah well on a side note too
on a side note
i actually have ex-muslims
who message me on email which i
appreciate you know
reaching out to me one-on-one
they reach out to me and they'll send
like this video link
and the video link will be like oh um
christians killed by muslims
or something like that and i watched the
video i'm like
all right this is it's kind of silly
because
when you're trying to like make me not
believe in islam
just because of this when it's like a
christian
wouldn't stop believing in christianity
just because of what the kkk did
yeah you know what i mean so i was like
i saw that i'm like bro
you do understand like
people are not perfect and we are
literally at the risk of sinning at the
risk of like doing things wrong
and bro he commented he he sent a
message but he said oh
i'm sorry i don't speak english too i'm
like bro what
like you don't you don't speak english
too well but you're over here sending me
videos that are in english
all right well idiotic um and i
let's let's think about it let's let's
use that kind of logic if you're a part
of a group
where if any individual or portion of
that group
does something that is deemed by society
to be wrong or immoral or bad
against allah then you would have to
make your own way of life
because even atheism look at what stalin
did
buddies with hitler look what he was
doing you would have to denounce atheism
you can't even say i'm an atheist and
but they might say oh atheism is not
atheism isn't a way of life islam
doesn't teach that
so why should i denounce islam because
of people who claim to be muslim what
they're doing you
if you follow that logic you can't be
atheist anymore claim belief for god and
claim deism
and khalas that's it and then when you
find that there is a deist that did
something bad in the past
you must be like i'm going to make my
own way of life that nobody can
infiltrate and ruin the name of it's
it's a pathetic argument but this is
what they do
thank you this is what they do they
appeal to a shock factor
emotion right they like there's one guy
in tick tock all like
recently all he said i know him i know
him i know you talking about paul
no no not him not him no oh not paul
someone else i'm talking about the
atheist troll guy oh
bro this yeah his last video oh he does
you believe in slavery you don't my man
you don't know what morality is that's
exactly what rituan was doing during
that daniel debate too he was just
bringing up classic arguments like
everyone deserves to be free he didn't
even have anything to say like
yeah see this is the thing man they'll
make these claims which
people generally agree with people
deserve to be free and even islam
doesn't have a problem with that this is
the thing
islam encourages freeing slaves we don't
have a problem with that
the abolishment of slavery even though
muslims were kind of thinking about it
in the beginning skeptical in the
beginning
allah made out of watch we abolish it
allah also encouraged freeing slaves if
we abolish it everyone's free
we don't have a problem with islamically
right they would never admit that but
yeah
but this is the issue they appeal to
shock factor because when
think about slavery and the the
connotation it has
sorry i know we're on this is kind of
random but this topic
do you guy have you guys read what's in
the 13th amendment which is um
abolishing slavery
it's it's insha allah if i remember
correctly i'm going to try and quote it
i might paraphrase a bit it says
that slavery or for enforced labor
um of any kind was now abolished
except for um forced labor as
a as a punishment for example prison
labor there is a form of slavery in
america today
and it's prison labor but they get mad
when they hear about something like
captives of war
as a punishment they are now slaves but
it's going on in their backyard
they've had no problem today and slavery
was only abolished in what the the 1600s
or something like that
or no that was it the 1800s
i think it was much later than 1600s
that's what i know
i think it was the late 1800s yeah yeah
i think
it's 18 something and then ends with the
six that's where i got confused yeah
what's up
just for mohammed i'm gonna go as far as
to say
that you saw that compilation
oh i saw that i saw that bro
it's slavery yeah yeah slavery is not
just
for the people that are locked up like
you got to look at slavery from an even
deeper perspective like
look at everyone who's in this uh
quote-unquote american dream over here
in the usa
like bro these people are doing things
they don't want to do
they're working jobs they don't want to
work they're over here making all this
money to get all these things to impress
people that they don't really care about
yeah so it's like if you think about it
those people are slaves
bro when i worked at a restaurant i
remember i was working like
14 to 18 hour shifts
bro it was so crazy and i'm telling you
in this restaurant
as i'm doing this work as i'm cleaning
the tables picking up after people i'm
like yo
i am literally a slave right now i am
serving these people cleaning up after
them
taking their trash and when i say trash
i really want to say
s-h-i-t but you know for a lot of
purposes we're not gonna go there
but y'all get the picture right these
people would treat me
terribly and i had to take it bro i just
had to take it
because i needed money
so like is that slavery or is that not
slavery i'll let y'all decide on that
that's kind of the same thing that
daniel was saying too like
if you don't want to work then you get
kicked out on the streets and no one
cares about you or else you have to work
all these long hours just to keep your
house just to keep your house
if you don't you're out on the street
and you don't got nothing
that's kind of slavery yeah you know
omar salehman actually has like
a very i think a very good series of i
think uh hours worth of lecturing on
this topic
and i want to add i want to add i hear
that even with the abolishment of
slavery in america
you had people you had slaves who after
slavery was abolished they went back to
their owners and begged them to take
them back because
there were people and just think about
it there are people who would rather be
a slave who was taken care of
than a poor person with nothing
and if relating it to what we just
brother angel just mentioned
it's basically the same thing you're
essentially a slave to this corporation
company restaurant whatever it is
in the sense that you need them to
survive otherwise you're going to be
living on the street having a horrible
life
except it's it's you have the freedom to
leave and then go be a slave somewhere
else how is that really freedom
at least at least in islam the slave has
rights
they have rights to be taken care of and
if the rights are violated
they're freed if they're even harmed in
any way or disrespected
or if they're harmed they're freed if
they're disrespected obviously it's not
allowed
and they could take it to a judge
alcalde whatever they need they have the
right to work and buy their own freedom
if they want
they have the right to get married and
like all of this stuff so it's like
it's just the picture that's been
painted you know the the the whip
yeah and that stuff on slavery um
let me know but what about um hold up
aside from
slavery yeah a big one that people want
to point out
is that if you leave islam then you're
killed
yeah um see this okay let me let me
finish this point
man i'm about to add to the collection i
just i forgot what i was going to say
let me let me let me give you let me
give you something yeah you got to do
that for
bro oh yo i forgot what i was going to
say that was this name perfect for
romney
but let me add some paint to that so you
think about all these
you're talking about slavery right and
one thing they use as ammunition
is i'm not going to mention these for
obvious reasons but
there's a lot of muslim countries right
namely
one that's deemed the holiest country
and you guys you got slavery here you
got you got videos on the internet of
them
beating and abusing and you know
mistreating this their their servants
and
it's like bro like they'll use that and
they'll be like look this is a real
islam this is what
muslims are and it's like bro i gotta i
gotta listen
i'm not gonna validate what you're
saying but i will acknowledge that
some of the most muslim countries are
out here being the most corrupt
yeah yeah see this is the thing sharia
is based on the khalafa the islamic
leader
we don't have one islamic leader we have
all these different countries they all
have their different laws and different
interpretations
and i'm sorry when certain places make
alliances with certain places
that are killing muslims the hell do you
expect these people thousand percent
really doesn't make sense and also what
i want to mention again
was again islam doesn't have a problem
with the abolishment of slavery some
can even say that where we're for it and
slave if any place
if any muslim place is practicing
slavery in the name of islam that within
itself is problematic
because the muslims at a time agree to
abolish slavery and islam does not have
a problem with abolishing slavery
and again some people would say it's in
favor of that
so uh this is like this is against islam
so they can't use the argument and again
if it's coming from an atheist what are
they gonna say
i subjectively believe this okay
congratulations cool
but um angel you mentioned
apostasy apostasy this is the thing the
hadith says
whoever leaves or whoever abandons their
religion
pause pause how's your mom doing
my mom yeah alhamdulillah she's doing
good very well continue
thank you thank you i appreciate it it's
good um
the hadith says who whoever abandons
their religion
and forsakes the community why do they
cut out half the hadith
because it doesn't sound as powerful
whoever abandons their religion
and forsakes the community put them to
death
now the reason for this is it's
basically treason it's breaking a social
contract
it's committing treason there are places
in the u.s where if you uh
i don't know if it's still in the us uh
that if you commit trees and you're
killed but there are places in the world
where if you chemistries and you're
killed
and in canada if you came in treason
they'll throw you in jail for 40 years
and revoke your citizenship it's not
exactly killing you
but that's like the highest form of
punishment in canada because that's
tough
it's pretty soft yeah but if someone
abandons a religion for sexy community
then they're put to death
but they quote the first half of the
hadith saying if anyone says i'm not
muslim
okay time to cut their head off or
something whoa
you guys saw that so hold up i did not i
did not see that but you're saying
that people who left islam
but initially just they just kind of
went their own way but they still
respected everything they still
respected islam they respected the
muslims
and they treated everyone you know
fairly and with love and everything like
that
those people would be all right yeah but
then if you had people like uh the uh
apology is it the apologetics
is that what is it called through such
thing as atheist apologetics
i think it's um there's a word apologist
apologist apologist
so these apologists like the people who
are here on youtube trying to like
spread this word about islam and just
try to demonize and everything like
these would be the
people who would initially be stoned to
death
yeah because like i'm not saying that
like we'll go and go ahead because like
the whole society is based on islam so
like if you're out here like
just talking down on islam insulting the
prophet insulting muslims then you're
pretty much committing treason
in an islamic state so like you're
trying to turn people away from islam
and the whole government is based on
islam so you're causing this
disorder and corruption everywhere
exactly bro it's not it's not
leaving the religion yeah it's not about
causing this harmony it's leaving the
religion
and causing disorder yeah and this is
the thing because even then even in that
case
you don't just say okay to the chopping
block right you you actually as far as i
know you consult them for like three
days
three days you literally it says take
them put them in a secure place
consult them for three days let them
know what's gonna happen like listen man
let's
if you keep doing this you know we're
gonna do this we're gonna do that just
stop it now
you're not helping you're causing
corruption just stop it and at that
point that person's not an innocent
person
they're intentionally trying to cause
disunity they're intentionally trying to
commit treason at this point for three
days they recited the words of allah
trying to be brought back to islam or at
least getting them to stop doing what
they're doing
stop forsaking the community and even
bro this is the most beautiful part
that's not even the that's not even the
necessary solution
because muhammad hijab mentioned in the
the debate with apostate prophet
that it's islamically feasible it's
islamically coherent
that you would have a treaty with a
non-muslim land
and if you have apostates you just
transport them there yeah you just ship
them away
yeah exactly yeah it's it's all for
keeping social order basically it's not
about oh this person left their religion
i think so exactly but these people
again they want this shock factor
y'all wanna y'all wanna know what's just
as beautiful bro so
remember remember a couple episodes ago
i know you guys know that rami brought
up how uh we need four male witnesses in
islam
we brought the whole thing about you
know judicial systems and having
witnesses
and there was hadith the prophet saw had
a man and a man committed a grave sin
and the man came to the prophet and said
hey you know i did this
and uh the prophet was like okay are you
sure um and he was like yeah i'm sure
and then the prophet saws
okay cool um just didn't didn't take any
action on it
the guy came back another day and he was
like hey man like i i i
committed the sin and the prophet said
islam was like okay are you are you
certain like are you mentally sound
are you mentally ill do you have any any
symptom of anything else he was like
nope i'm sound cool
came back another day uh the prophet
saws was like okay cool
are you under the influence of any
intoxicant and and the prophet saws did
this four
times right because you need four male
witnesses until he was sure that the man
committed the sin yeah
and at this point let's keep in mind
this man knows what's going to happen to
him
he's intentionally like like he's asking
for it basically that's why
he testified four times the story i
heard the story i heard was that he
he came to boston and said i did this
and the process i sent him said no you
didn't and he walked away
yeah and then that happened four times i
did it no you didn't i didn't know i
didn't
i know you didn't four times and then he
came back and prophesied
and said i i did it the fourth time or
something and
yeah and then the prophet saw then he
said
are you crazy are you like are you mad
because if he's mad he doesn't know what
he's saying he's like go he says no i'm
not he's like
like are you drunk because if he's drunk
he's safe he's let go he doesn't know
what 100
thinking uh but again this happened the
only time these these
like capital punishments took place as
far as i know was when people
uh testified against themselves for time
literally asking for the punishment and
at that point it's like
if we didn't do it they would have done
something to themselves yeah
dude and if y'all think about this right
i completely forgot what i was gonna say
i mean uh you're picking up on ramy's uh
memory blue city bro i'm gonna have both
of y'all take some uh
what was that lion's mane mushroom y'all
ever tried that
it's one of those uh those supplements
they call them
nootropics or nootropics right and it's
like a blur it's a brain supplement
completely natural bro
uh i never you know experimented with
those but i heard those are good
i'm pretty sure that hello okay i
remember
i remember all right so if y'all think
about this
as humans what do we do
with other humans like when we always
want to share something
all right we either want to share
something that we did something that we
experience
or is something that we are feeling
right like if i feel happy bro i want to
share that with y'all
yeah you know if i feel sad
well personally i wouldn't want to share
that with anyone but a lot of people
nowadays they feel sad
and they start sharing that with people
like bro i remember being a kid and
being on facebook
and just typing on like the facebooks
that is like oh i'm depressed
or on myspace typing up that i'm
depressed or something like that
i don't even know what depression was
i'm obviously saying i'm depressed but
anyways
what i'm trying to say is that as humans
we're always trying to share something
right and someone who is
leaving islam for whatever reason and
and
guys if you just pay attention to all
these people who are living islam
they're very emotional you know like
they're not they're not really
seeing things the way that they should
be they're seeing
misconstrued things their emotions are
getting in the way their mind
is altering all the things that are
coming up you know like
we could even go as far as to say that
they are
falling victim to the whispers of you
know who
right so this person is basically
being swayed in a path that's
causing them discomfort and then now
that they are leaving islam
they want to share because that's what
humans do we share
so imagine this person is feeling all
this discomfort all this
agony all these um uh conflicting ideas
these thoughts that are going on inside
them and then they're over here sharing
that with every other person
like now these other people are going to
start get
getting the same thing that this person
has and like that's where
it would be a dire thing where it's like
it would impact people in a big way
because like bro this guy um i don't
even know his name bro
the dude that uh hijab debated bro like
the one who made a video on me
like bro look at look at his content you
know like the
the little bit that i saw which was only
on the debate
with muhammad hijab bro it just it
showed me
the type of state that this individual
was in
and it's like just just know like anyone
who watches his videos you guys are
receiving
what he is transmitting and what he is
transmitting is the discomfort
and everything that he feels so it's
like it just makes sense
everything and i'm not trying to justify
the whole killing aspect but it's like
when you put it all together it all
clicks
you know what i mean yeah 100 i want to
i want to piggyback that point really
quick
because i would i would even go as far
as to say yes i would even go as far as
this
that most the most
popular islam haters are non-academics
there are people like like sam harris
but he's more pro-atheism and less
anti-islam
right um there are christian apologists
like uh
william lane craig and uh even
jordan peterson has a certain opinion on
on
uh islam yeah let me pause you right
there for a second i'm gonna
put my video off for a few minutes but
i'm gonna be in the audio
so i'm gonna hear you guys i'm gonna
respond everything just bear with me
i called you too bro all right you heard
about you heard about the the guy that
was exposed that muhammad hijab refuted
it was that a scientific guy
you know what you know what it's going
guys guys let me let me disregard the
picture
now let me let me tell you guys
something that that's so it's such a
shame but
our viewers are lovely viewers t3m
family
whenever anu turns out this camera he
has the most ridiculous profile pictures
known to man and it's a shame because
y'all are just probably seeing his name
and block text on him
but man
i can't see it oh you can't see it
no i can't i'm on mobile so oh it's
white
lightning yeah yeah
you should have been in gallery view bro
bro what is that bro
that's him bro that was him before he
accepted islam
yeah look what it's done for oh man yeah
it fixed that nose that's for sure yeah
as i was saying guys
so muhammad hijab talked about a man who
was in the scientific community
uh neil degrasse tyson
and he refuted him did you guys see that
video i recently yeah i watched it i
watched it
yeah tell us a little bit about it
because i think neil degrasse tyson is
what
he's a cosmologist and he's very
anti-islam
it was just so dumb like he was saying
that islamic history had no science he
was saying that
um he was you know like al ghazali
yeah yeah yeah so he was saying that al
ghazali is the one who put islam
together and that it was all
just disorder and chaos before that and
everyone was interpreting the quran the
way they wanted to
um that was ridiculous it was something
like that
yeah i wouldn't say i wouldn't say
that's necessarily wrong because we did
have disagreements
um and there were some certain people in
islamic history that um
really brought the truth forth but they
did it based on the quran and sunnah
right it's not like they came and it
added added things right yeah yeah
narrative
yeah without the quran he was like the
main guy
and it was like nah bro if anything he's
he's done a lot for the the sufism
community
and not sufi as in modern day what
they're doing and you know those
spinning and all
dancing and chanting no but he's done a
lot for bringing sufism in terms of
just meditation and like properly
accepting the spirituality in the roch
man yeah but he was saying that islam
basically had like no foundations until
al ghazali
[Music]
and he was saying that there was no
science there was nothing invented or
something like that
there was no science or anything like
that in the history of islam that's what
he was pushing
what is that tell us tell us
i was gonna say sorry just a thought
wouldn't that um
kind of wouldn't that uh be in favor of
islam with all the
because islam in the quran is in line
with 21st century science
so if there is no science at the time no
way to know these things and the
prosperity wouldn't that be in favor of
islam if it didn't come about until
later but it's in the quran which came
before
i don't really understand the argument
but insha'allah i'll watch the video
yeah but i love i love the way muhammad
hijab algorithm chased on that one
the title were just perfect mm-hmm like
when you just search up muslim
schools it pops up muslim schools
neil degrasse tyson i love how he did
that yeah
it got a lot of views too yeah i did man
100
congrats to alhamdulillah all goes to
angel
for finally hitting 100k views on his
my convert story my rebirth story
because these are the videos that truly
require viewers
i want to give a big shout out to arami
as well
you know for all you do for the channel
all your wisdom all your knowledge
i want to give another shout out to
muhammad ibn
the time traveler bro and i wanna i
wanna get to know a little bit more
about you and for the viewers that don't
really know
my first question to you would be how
did you find our channel
um i don't really remember how i found
your channel like it was on the
it was like around the time when i was
like getting off a tick tock and i was
like pulling away like
i completely deleted the app i used to
be on tiktok i never really made videos
like that but yeah so
and then i saw like i saw like
promotions here and there for the
podcast
so i was like cool i didn't know i
didn't know you and i didn't know
i well i knew angel but i didn't
recognize who he was but he looked
familiar so i was like
let me just go to their channel and just
give them a sub you know and
i was kind of busy at the time so i
didn't watch episode one and then i came
on episode two
and i started leaving the time stamps i
was thinking like yo this has
this podcast has the potential to be
something big one day so i was like i'm
going to help out with the time stamps
so i put it i was like i'll be trying to
keep up and leave the timestamps
that's pretty much how i found it pretty
much off of like tick tock
or instagram like those areas um
so it's not the the traditional you know
you found romney's tick tock or you
watched on how's river story with the
podcast
it was it was you just came across it
through the color of allah
and then you just you just came from the
jump all right so if you guys have made
it this far
we did mention that we're going to have
a special announcement today
so we are officially and publicly
extending our invite
and it's all it's going to go to
muhammad ibn the time traveler you are
now officially a part of the t3m
the three muslims podcast team you are
going to be equal
to all of us not better not worse and
from now on man
you are responsible for always doing the
time stamps
and guys if you guys are wondering these
these past few weeks you've been seeing
these crisp
clean thumbnails it's all it's all you
it's all i've been so you've been you've
been handling all these amazingly
masha allah we are gonna look forward to
launching a t3m highlight or t3m clips
channel
just like you know a lot of other
podcasts have rolling and we're gonna
make sure that you are responsible for
handling that too
so all the back end work of the
foundation
you're basically the brains of the
operation
so this is all going to be you yeah
and i just want to give you a big
physical care thank you
for all that you've done so far without
even being a part of the team
it really goes to show about your
character your integrity and your
support
for the podcast as a whole yes
congratulations brother that means
hey that means now you're gonna help us
pay taxes
this guy's profile pick caught me off
guard again facts i don't even think
you're old enough to pay taxes are you
no no no i'm 16
yo so low-key why don't you handle all
of our income just for just for the next
for the future get some
a little bit of tax evasion i'm just
playing yeah so
so next next i want to get into okay now
that that's over with get a little bit
more into you
um tell us more about you where you live
kind of your upbringing in brief
whatever you feel comfortable sharing
and if you have any questions for us let
us know those before you go because they
might be on your mind
okay so i'm just i'm just a regular
teenager
i live in washington i lived in uh
kent covington area but now i'm like in
spanaway
i'm i'm i don't think you guys know
because like those are the smaller
cities
but like yeah so i've been just chilling
my religious upbringing was just
i was given the foundations like believe
in allah believe in the prophets
the quran is the scripture like that's
where we get our knowledge from
and then later on like it started like
when i was 11 12-ish
i started getting into the proofs and
all this the first
the first thing that i found like the
first doubt
of islam or like the first doubt or
shubaha that was thrown at islam
that that came to me was the surah 9
suratoba about the verse about killing
disbelievers and stuff
and i came across it from david's
channel so like after that it was just
i just kept going and going and i delved
deep into it i started watching
zuckernak videos
and all the scientific miracles and all
that and
that's how i kind of got my faith
by proof basically
[Music]
were you born in somalia or were you
born here nah i was born here
yeah i could tell bro i could tell yeah
um but
do you have you got any siblings yeah i
have siblings i have a brother who's 15.
i have a sister who's 9
10 and then another sister who's five
and another sister who's
like three months old so yeah and you
are 16 years old
yeah i'm the only you're the oldest of
the pack you're the leader of the tribe
and you have four siblings i'm not
surprised that's that's typical
somali typical african households man
that's y'all doing good for the
man i had a fifth one but he passed away
so
but it was that's like as an infant yeah
as a man rest in peace they will be in
peace he's an infant
yeah fox may he rest in peace bro
yep thousand percent man
all right bro i'm just curious man a lot
of viewers are too what did you do in
this mean time that you turned your
camera off
uh did you record did you record that
part when i had the camera
oh no we're talking no not you we're
talking about oh oh on hill
oh i thought it was me hello bro
uh
just listening you guys be honest that's
so creepy bro
i had to listen i had to turn the camera
off so i could like really listen to
what was being said you know like my
adhd was acting up
mm-hmm no no
for real i was just walking after i eat
i like to walk for like five ten minutes
it helps with your digestion
yeah it's very nice
that's dope man yo i know you got any
more questions for
muhammad
so you're 16. yep what are your hobbies
right now bro
um just helping you guys watching muslim
videos
well when there was no quarantine i was
playing basketball
and that's pretty much it i'm a hooper
you uber
okay yes sir yes sir hey romney's a
hooper too
yes yes how tall are you how tall are
you which one
you me i'm 5 11.
oh i'll probably dunk on you
okay
i'm five seven yeah i feel average like
i feel like
you're gonna be six
i knew you were tall yeah he looks tall
doesn't he
like just when you look at him in the
videos he's got the the long frame
yeah a lot of people have been telling
me though that when they see our podcast
like they think he's short
like they're like yo i thought romney's
like five years i i i actually suffered
i'm like i don't know
subconsciously i always think he's
shorter really damn
maybe because you're like slimmer a
little bit so like i don't know and then
you're like
it's like the top part is only showing
so i'm like
yeah mohammed bro we're gonna have to
play basketball one day bro
yeah we're gonna have to play basketball
i'm gonna have to break your ankles just
as i'm gonna break romney's bro
all right keep talking man keep talking
it ain't tough hey robbie did you ever
play on a basketball team
uh i did for a bit yeah on in high
school and
on rep okay wow how about you
correct bro i never got chosen on a
basketball team
yeah but i'm really good though yeah
good
good mashallah man i was um i played on
teams outside of school
because when i was in sixth grade i got
humiliated man like it was such a sad
story bro
i was um trying out for the the
basketball team i was so sure of myself
because like i had been training
for like two years now and i was like oh
bro i'm gonna make this
easy and i had just made uh like a good
friend on the bus
i'm not gonna say his name or anything
that's irrelevant
bro in the basketball tryouts
we were in the gym everyone was like
sitting down and they would have like
these pickup games just so the coach
could like see
your skills he could assess your defense
he could assess your awareness your
offense
your ability to shoot pass cross all
that good stuff
bro and man like me and this other kid
and then all these other dudes were just
spinning around on the ground
acting like fools bro the coach looked
back at us he's like hey all of y'all
y'all can leave bro i remember i was
like no no coach
i'm sorry i i ain't mean to i ain't mean
to
and bro like you say no no no y'all want
to play games y'all can leave my gym i
was like coach please please like give
me another chance
didn't give me another chance but i
remember i was crying so much bro
bro i cried so hard bro i cried so hard
and then i just
uh i didn't try out it was like
something that just kept stopping me
from trying out
i still break your angles though
we'll see about that just for the record
that coach is an absolute soy boy
that is such a like what a waste man he
killed but i mean
if you're a coach bro if you're a coach
and you see something like kids fooling
around
like i'm i'm sorry but i would have sent
them home too
no at least a warning first like under
yeah i would have i would have warned
them first like
like yeah and kids they're kids come on
yeah
it is it is what it is though y'all it
is what it is i think it's still
breaking
news all right could have been in the
nba right now
i could have but you know what allah's
plan is greater than ours bro here i am
about to go into mma mashallah
yes sir bro that why do you think i said
the whole thing about fighting
and like i don't debate like i use my my
body my hands my legs my knees
maybe you're just a street fighter maybe
just a street fighter
with hall of fame intimidation
man's trying to mentor you do you think
you think i'm intimidating bro
no not anymore
yeah like his face changed his face
changed i don't know
but really brother i'll be walking i'll
be walking places and
and people do get scared people get
intimidated and i have to like
remind myself that people get
intimidated so i have to smile
and like be more uh kind to people in
order for them to be like all right
yeah but now you're now you're the
friendly giant
as my brother in islam so much
it's good to have that balance though
yeah balance you know being able to
put it on take it off and you need that
you need that because sometimes you need
to be a little grungy sometimes you need
to be nice
i mean my bad like an american
yo so you said you played basketball you
you haven't played basketball
in a little bit right yeah in a long
time
i haven't played since like june wow
damn dude yeah i bet you are you missing
it
uh yeah i'm missing it i'm i'm missing
it a lot
why are you not playing there's no
basketball courts around here
and i just moved so like
there is no basketball courts nearby
anywhere i don't even think there's a
gym here
that's tough yo what if we like
do you have people around you that also
want to play
oh yeah my dad plays my brother plays
bro what if we start this man a gofundme
to get him a basketball hoop
and a basketball
we could not oh my god i'm down
that's actually a good idea yeah at the
end of the day man
you got hoop dreams i'm not saying you
want to be in the nba but i'm not not
saying that so why not we just we just
do what we can to just
get you back to what you were already
doing because times are tough man it's
clover there's no gems open
here's the thing you got no gyms near
you or who courts near you
if we had some near us we still wouldn't
be able to play because we're in
full lockdown lockdown the states is on
some other stuff but
uh why not man where are you where are
you from
where are you at right now we are i'm in
a city called waterloo an hour away from
toronto
and rami is in where are you at i'm in
mississauga like right beside toronto
yeah but we're both in ontario so same
provincial both in ontario but not
ontario california
you guys are in canada yeah we're in
canada where are you at i know
i'm in dubai right now damn you're in
dubai
that's crazy bro i was gonna go to dubai
nah nah i'm not in dubai i'm in florida
right now
wow florida so we're in the opposite
corners of the u.s
yes sir no bro but
listen we're gonna do this go fund for
you
all right we're gonna get this
basketball court we're gonna get we're
not a basketball coach that'd be a
little too much off
we're gonna get you the basketball hoop
and we're gonna get you a basketball
and bro at some point inshallah
we'll all get together yeah so one i can
cross
you and rami and two bro i can uh
this is introduce you into martial arts
oh yeah yeah i've been what is
the fact that you're getting let me let
me
know because i'm a practice for you
[Music]
wait all right listen listen have you
have you traveled a lot or no mohammed
uh the only place i've been to the only
place i've been to was in
kenya nairobi and i've been there
i traveled bro listen listen
i travel a lot alhamdulillah not as much
as
obviously on hell i don't know
huh i think you travel more than me bro
i'm capping bro
but i'm trying to get you two to travel
more and so we were just talking
on the low about t3m the three of us
were planning a trip sometime not not
gonna be immediately soon but sometime
that works out
and bro if you're a part of t3m you're
coming with us so
it's gonna be a dope trip where you guys
got plans to go
just waiting honestly bro no
i'm thinking somewhere like switzerland
what's up man this
have you seen switzerland in the summer
bro it's hella warm
no bro we got to go somewhere tropical
bro
we can't go to somewhere tropical bro
listen if we can go to switzerland we
can go
somewhere tropical no i'm saying like we
can bro cause
you want to go somewhere tropical bro go
to the beach
bro go to miami go to a tropical area
and bro even the beaches in florida
ain't really
tropical like bro i'm an island boy i'm
from puerto rico like
i know what tropical is and like florida
ain't tropical my dude
have you ever been back to uh puerto
rico recently
and then for you have you been back to
somalia recently
i've never been to someone go first bro
nowhere never been to kenya but not
somalia
yeah because most of my family's in
kenya
they moved from somalia to kenya so
they're all just chilling there it's
nearby at least
but like i was
yeah gone oh i was i was a little bit
too young to remember i remember a
little bit because i was like
in fourth grade but like i remember some
experiences and then
i forgot most of it
did they teach you how to run
what do you mean bro
canyons have like the best form when it
comes to running
i never ran i was always chilling in the
this house bro
listen i'm gonna introduce you to
martial arts i'm about to hand you ass
to you a little bit just so you can
start learning and
two bro i'mma have to like get you
started in terms of like
more exercise more using your body and
like getting outside man because
me bro hey the prophet said it best man
like you need to be a strong you need to
have a strong body
yep like bro randy why don't you once
you say that little line
again because it's left my mind if i uh
if i remember if if i'm we're talking
about the same thing we're on the same
wavelength
said that the strong believer is better
than the weak believer although they
both have good
that's me that's it presume
yeah hey what you trying to do like
in terms of maybe your career dream job
your purpose you know no clue man
taking day by day just day by day just
putting trust in allah
there you go i mean yeah there you go
but okay so i get it it's beautiful
putting your trust in allah that's how
it should be but are you taking the
steps necessary
to start figuring it out because you
can't just sit back like this
and be like all right well yeah
like what are we gonna do miracles to
happen
so what are you doing bro just chilling
in school
just chilling in school you know just
chilling man let him chill let him do it
yeah bro
he's relaxing bro listen
when i was 16 years old if i could go
back and talk to myself at 16
number one i'd smack myself across the
face
and number two is i would start to tell
myself
to like just do more like don't be so
content and comfortable with just
chilling uh
going on the internet playing video
games watching tv
hanging out with friends and stuff like
that like bro the more things you try
the closer you're gonna get to like
finding what it is
that's for you you feel me like again
like we can't sit back
but we also can't be so like in a rush
to find what it is like
the more you look for something the more
it's gonna elude you
so it's just a matter of like trying new
things because if
if i would have been trying new things
like i probably would have came on to
uh mma or just martial arts in general
like way
sooner than now at 20
i i i uncovered it around like 25
26 so like i could have probably
uncovered that by like 1920
if i would have been trying new things
you feel me it's like that's why i ask
you like what are you doing
yeah i can't say the same to be honest i
would just let myself be
and uh humdina
yeah that's true but i see all those
points at the end of the day
because you gotta know at least what you
like bro so you know what you gonna like
and not what you're gonna dislike yeah
but at the end of the day
i'm only going to speak for myself right
now in terms of
having one life purpose again
i don't think i don't think i found it
but i will say
even though i'm in grad school right now
and i'm doing this podcast
i don't know too much about other things
but this podcast i'm never going to stop
and i'm pretty sure rami on hell
muhammad you guys are now on the same
boat like
this podcast this is bigger than us
right like when we die youtube is gonna
stay
yeah youtube might might do some you
know
dumb stuff and you know delete our
channel or demonetize because you know
the truth has enemies now come on now
and who cares because we'll still have
patreon we'll start the lives that we
have
impacted and influenced through the
grace of allah those people are going to
continue
to pay it forward so at the end of the
day it's a win-win but until then this
is not stopping
yeah let's say one day i don't really
work and i don't open my own
you know clinic and i keep doing
whatever whatever i'm doing this
podcast's thing like i'm still going to
devote my life into this
and i'm pretty sure you know angel let's
say i'm not going to say mma is not
going to work out
but let's just say if it does work out
or if it doesn't
you still rather die for this and that's
the same with youtube
so the other day the way things are
looking right now i'm not gonna say t3m
is my purpose but it is a
purpose and it's something that i
haven't
actively sought out it's something that
just came to me
and it's almost like a lot gave it to us
all right bro let me let me clarify a
little bit for you so
for a long time i was on this whole wave
of purpose like you have to find your
purpose you have to have this purpose
and like once i got into islam i really
understood like okay the true purpose
is to come back to the creator like to
navigate through this dunya
and to be on that straight path because
i mean like bro
like i could have my purpose in martial
arts but then that'll end and then what
i could have my purpose in extreme
sports like skydiving wingsuit flying
and all this stuff but at some point
that's gonna end
and it's like then what so i'll i'll go
as far
and i'm gonna say it again bro i go as
far as to say i'ma
reframe it instead of saying purpose
because we already know what our purpose
is our purpose is
to worship the creator and come back to
the creator and stay on that straight
path
get past this damn dunya because this is
the test this is
temporary this is so temporary as
compared to what's to come
so i instead of purpose it's more so
passion and it's like what are you
passionate
about and you could be passionate about
a lot of things
but there's going to be one thing that's
like when you do it
you don't have to think about it you
don't have to
rationalize you don't have to justify it
just
it hits you but like it smacks you
across the face like ah
this is it you know what i mean and like
it it takes a while to get there bro
like or it might not
it's it's literally like when when
you're ready when a lot was it but
just to reframe it for you because it's
not purpose it's more passion
you used to used to be on that on that
purpose train like yo
y'all everyone has one purpose you gotta
find it but it's like
it's not so black and white and once you
connect psalm i know you're seeing this
full and clear right now that the one
purpose you want wrong
there is still one purpose yeah exactly
but it's like exactly
in terms of like what you want to do in
this dunya you still can't just be
sitting back be like oh i'm gonna just
do whatever nah
you still gotta make a living because
you know islam tells us that being close
to being
uh broke and being in poverty is being
close to being a disbeliever
so we still have to do something with
our life that's the way you came in
tying it
into the passion right but it's
multifaceted
in this dunya that's the beauty of it
let's say you like basketball all right
you don't like that's your passion but
there's not one thing
you don't have to be in the nba what if
you love basketball
but you love helping people even more ah
then you can be a basketball coach
right what if you love basketball but
you you're not really
into the playing of it but you love the
sport okay why don't you be
someone that designs basketball shoes
there's so much you could do
with one passion you know what i mean
like just like t3m we're not all doing
the same thing but it's all for one
cause right
so yeah at the end of the day like
that's the beauty of anything
but the bro and what's even more
beautiful
is that the passion connects with the
purpose
because like whatever it is that you're
passionate about you're going to be
putting
everything that you got into it and when
you put everything you got into it
you're putting
like your soul you sweat your blood your
tears bro
everything you're putting it into what
you're doing
and like the person who's on the
receiving end
and is receiving whatever it is that
you're giving
like bro they are receiving nothing but
purity bro like if i'm over here like i
have this huge passion for mma and then
i'm teaching
i'm a coach and i'm showing you like bro
this
is what works and i'm like literally
taking my time with you step by step
showing you every single movement how
your body's functioning
which muscles are activating which
ligaments are being pulled here
and like everything to where you just
you're grasping everything perfectly bro
like you're gonna get more from that
than someone who's just an mma coach
for the money which ain't really that
much money in it but let's just say he's
in it for the money
there's no real passion in it he's
teaching you something but he's you're
not really receiving
that gift you know what i mean in like
that's where it ties back in with like
your purpose
which we're talking about the purpose is
worshipping allah
coming back to the straight path getting
past this dunya
it's like bro
you lead by example right
you could sit here and say all this
stuff but if you leave by example and
you're doing your passion
like you're essentially spreading dawah
without
saying anything about islam that's
beautiful man i wanted to i wanted to
add to that that train that you're on
right now and a lot of people hit us up
in patreon in our requests in our dms
in email in our inbox whatever you want
to say we've gotten this question a lot
where do you draw the line between
helping people about islam and people
that are just like lost causes or like
not lost causes because only allah knows
best but
there's no progress that you can make
with them i know i know
you guys have each had a friend or two a
brother or sister in your life where you
try to you know bring them on the
straight path
but they just don't want to see it and
they just don't want to believe it and
they just don't want to let their ego
down and it's like i always categorize
people into three
um different groups and the first one is
like people that
you're you can make a little bit of
progress with all right these are the
people that are kind of susceptible
kind of you know open to influence so
you can bring them into allah's path
i would say these people go at it 100
not go at it as in like completely
but definitely do your best don't push
them away from islam
but definitely bring them forward don't
loaf down it don't sit on it all right
these are difficult conversations but
conversations that need to be had
nonetheless
all right the second group is people
that have kind of no interest all right
you could tell that
you've kind of been putting in work or
they kind of don't want to they don't
want to accept islam they're kind of
islamophobic they have too much
programming that they need to overcome
themselves but they're not doing the
necessary steps
i'm not going to say call us and just
abort it but i would say don't spend as
much time on these people
and try to find people in the first
group because these people no matter
what
some people are genuine here to just not
be with the program
and muhammad sent me a text last night
how um
allah literally says that of all the
people that leave islam
allah will replace them with people that
are better for the demon for the ummah
so
i think that's profound and there's a
third group with people obviously that
are super high interest
right these are the people that are like
nah man they're they're coming to you
you don't have to come to them they're
already expressing interest
these are the people in our dm's that
are like yo how do i do the shahada
these are the people like kevin from
ireland shout out to you brother
these people i would say again it's a
no-brainer just accept them with open
arms bring them into the straight path
of allah inshaallah allah accepts your
guidance
to them but regardless of what i'm
saying to bring it into
onho's point all three of these groups
you're going to have to lead by example
it has to show for all of them guys no
matter if they're number two
which is the uninterested islamophobic
anti-islam atheist
either way bro none of these three
people are going to meet you
and not be led by your example in some
way shape or form towards islam they
might not agree with it
but your o'clock has to be universal and
it needs to be
constant to everyone man bro there's a
quote that says be so good that they
can't ignore you
and obviously bro they could have so
many
uh we could apply that to so many things
but when we're talking about
leading by example bro be so pure in
your actions
that like when people see you they they
can't ignore you bro they can't
just disregard you they see you and they
see
like how good of a person you are how
good you treat others
how loving you are how emotionally uh
intelligent you are how grounded you are
how bro like how positive you are where
you can bring
someone else into that positive state
you know what i'm saying like it
when you meet someone like that you
don't you can't disregard them because
they are having such a
huge impact on you so it's like bro if
you can lead like that
people will feel so amazing being around
you they're gonna
start getting curious like yo why are
you like this
why are you so happy why are you so
joyful
why are you so um just grounded
and then bro like that's where you can
start sliding in little seeds
and then with those little seeds and
they start watering it themselves over
time and then at some point or another
if allah was it they will come
100 man and guys at the end of the day
like
what i'm trying what we're trying to say
essentially is like before all that
you got to get yourself straight how are
you going to lead other people by
example if
you have this mentality that oh when i'm
behind closed doors it's okay if i
if i eat this twinkie or it's okay if
you know i'm watching things i shouldn't
be watching and it's like bro
at the end of the day did you forget
that allah tells us that
never is it three people among you
except that i'm the fourth
whenever is it that there's two among
you committing a sin or
murder or whatever except that i'm the
third what i'm trying to say is allah is
always watching
so at the end of the day yeah there's
closed doors but how do you act when no
one's watching are you praying salah
when no one's watching and you don't
have to
boast about salah are you doing things
and taking care of yourself
when the highlight and the focus and the
limelight is not on you
because if you can do that i guarantee
you it's not going to be hard to do it
with other people and lead them by
example
because khabib you know professional mma
fighter
and amazing muslim subhanallah so he's
not all right bro
habib he's not out here doing
walk you know behind closed doors right
you get what i mean he's now here eating
whatever and
doing whatever and watching whatever not
so at the end of the day
we can all learn by example and it was a
good point masha'allah
you had something to say bro you were
you were quiet for a bit obstacle prayer
also
you still didn't pray also bro i mean
when we started
it was it just hit us i prayed before i
okay i'll be back and we're going to
brought this up anyway so how long has
it been
it's been just i don't know over an hour
wow time flies yeah bro that's how it is
that's how it is when we talk and so
this man
yeah so if you guys have made it this
far if you guys have
have tuned in this long all right this
is just for the special peeps
i'm not this this is not there's a
reason i didn't say this in the
beginning
but this is just for the loyal t3m
family that has made it this far
our next up and coming episode stay
tuned for one talking about the yuko
crisis in china
and stay tuned for another episode we're
going to be talking about money
finances is it important is it not and
anaha has more than
two cents to give towards that insha
allah
i do yes sir bro you've been schooling
me and romney about money since what
months ago
didn't i just ask you about like
investing before we talked about this
yeah i'm gonna teach you how to invest
but
there's more about the philosophy that
you know you were imparting your wisdom
on ah
and in general tips so i think that
deserves its own episode
and at the end of the day man money
isn't everything but not having it is
right so we got to make sure that we're
straight
and at the end of the day it's not
always about the benjamins but it's
about being able to buy
what money can buy like freedom helping
those around you let's say
your mom needs a surgery god forbid and
it's like oh man
i don't have the money like do you want
to be that guy or it's like nah i got
you mom
you know or your son wants to go to
college you don't want them going into
debt with riba and student loans you
could help them out
just little things like that really go
along the way and it keeps you away from
being a disbeliever
[Music]
now while we wait or before rami to come
back
i want you to share something with us
muhammad
something new that you've learned if
there's something new that you've
learned
after watching our podcast um
well the episode the episode with fahad
was like
the most impactful episode like it was
crazy like i
i had so much to learn like especially
the part when it comes to like
debating and stuff like it's not about
winning the argument it's about winning
the heart over
like and realizing that having a
discussion with someone is much better
than
just trying to argue and topple because
there's like egos involved and stuff
like that
so that was that was the most impactful
thing that i learned off this podcast
bro did it did it blow your mind when uh
yeah
the shake five was uh talking about the
and he was saying how like in the quran
it was uh
their perspective their perspective and
then it switches to first perspective
once he puts the rule inside of us
because allah can address us address us
once he's put
inside of us in our consciousness yes
that that episode was
amazing like we gotta have fahad back
oh we will let's believe that
we will yeah and uh this episode's gonna
come down well we gotta queue about a
month and a half now
so this episode is definitely coming out
in march but
nonetheless uh if you guys made it this
far please do your part all right you
guys are just important to t3 amazon's
because you guys are the actual viewers
so share this video it helps us
tremendously because as soon as we get
to 5k
subs we're dropping two weekly episodes
so that's going to be double
the engagement double the views and
double the amount of people that
inshallah can be
influenced and brought to the straight
path through the grace of allah
yeah man oh no you got something to say
yeah listen man
we're gonna get you this basketball hoop
and this basketball
i need you training bro cause if i come
out there
and you can't cross me and you can't
dunk me like you said that you can dunk
bro listen i'm gonna i'm gonna take that
basketball hoop apart and i'm gonna sell
it
oh yeah cause you gotta put your money
where your mouth bro you can't
you can't bark but i can't actually dunk
though i can't actually dunk but i know
i'll win though
i wouldn't you know you don't you don't
know how to dunk
nah i'm too short bro you said you could
dunk on me
i didn't mean it seriously i was playing
damn yeah i'm [ __ ]
you're gonna be on five eight five nine
when we meet all right well if you keep
playing
i haven't grown for like three years
you're gonna have to at least
cross me up because all i know is that
one imma break your ankles and two imma
have to
dunk on you bro can you duck
yes sir you're not dunking on me though
all right bro like i said we gonna give
you some time to train on that new
basketball
and i'm telling you bro if you can't
cross me i'm gonna take that basketball
hoop apart but i'm gonna come with the
tools and everything
i think we made it to the end of this
episode inshallah
why don't you close it off first unless
you got something to say on your mind
you made it this far comments hold up
hold up no no don't even say that yet i
want to ask
brother muhammad one question yeah
you trying to have four wives
no what nah man
just one yeah just one
just one what's your reasoning behind
that well my reasoning is
well the quran says that like no matter
how hard you try to be equal with your
wives
you can't be exactly equal and like
i would just feel discomfort just
knowing that like
the quran says yeah yeah it says that
like you
like you could try you could try your
best just don't make it like super
obvious like which one you're leaning to
but it says that
you can't like you can't really have the
same exact
feeling for all of them yeah that's true
even if you tried your hardest to do so
it's uncertain
yeah so like just try and be just with
them yeah just trying to be just but
like knowing that i'm not treating them
all the exact same
like to the detail that just
okay that would just make me feel like
worry in my heart
that's fair damn what a sweeter man bro
you see yourself getting married
um early 20s maybe
inshallah that's cool bro that's cool
man okay so hold up now okay with that
again may i love bless you for that
because i was that was real brother i
was pure
yeah yeah but now the question
lies in hand are you trying to have like
a real strong connection and like
romance with a woman
with like one woman or are you just
trying to uh
i don't even know how i'm trying to word
this here but the best way that i can
put it let me kind of take a step back
here
um if we look at the prophet peace be
upon him
when he was with hadija yeah
bro like that was his backbone like she
was his one
you know i mean and yeah that's why
i feel you bro i want that too he has
that
romney wants that and it's like every
man could say that he wants that but
then it's like look what happened
after the fact when adija passed away
it's like the man i'm not saying that
the man went
cold and he just didn't have the
connection with women like he did with
hadija but it's like now
instead of giving everything to one he's
like giving
a fair amount to all the ones that he's
broke and he's supporting them i agree
man 100
man and yo like my wife watches our
podcast so i'm going to say this right
now i know
i know i know you're watching but at the
end of the day i i hundred percent
can validate angela's thoughts right now
because if you're
if you got a girl if you got a wife
who's literally out here
being your backbone you're probably not
gonna think of
three more tryouts are open whatever you
want to say but
if you're not fully emotionally
physically whatever you want to say
spiritually
connected to them and fulfilled yeah
okay then that's what you need for it
and we all know about the story of the
prophet of islam in khalid
that was his backbone they were truly
connected
so yeah you know i could imagine how
like having someone like that taken away
from you
okay then you're kind of gonna okay i i
what if that happens again
yeah why not just diversify my portfolio
and allah just just to piggyback these
points masha allah
um it's amazing how the process he would
still praise
hadith to his wives
to the point where i you and she was
like mad like you know
i don't want to hear about her anymore
and he was like she was she was there
for me when no one else was
she he's basically saying she was my
backbone she was the everything to me
and she helped me so much
so i'm going to praise her whether you
like it or not but um he didn't say that
i'm sorry i'm sorry
just so we're fair he didn't say that
but um essentially the message is
if you have a hadith
you don't really need more but if you
don't
go for it
are you right i'm not doing something
i'm not good
you got all these feminists in our
comments always saying so basically what
you guys are saying is
yeah if a man has more than one wife
then it means the wives are lower value
yeah i mean essentially what we're
saying
on average on most cases yeah there's
some men that
even with a lot of they're not they're
not satisfied they still want more
but at the end of the day allah man our
worst thing is
at least i'm speaking on behalf of me
and i know muhammad can speak on behalf
of him
if you got one ride or die it's better
than having four that are kind of half
on the team yeah yeah true yeah i wanna
wanna i wanna ask something here i wanna
ask something i wanna be as fair as
possible right
um because what we're talking about it
like a man marries for for the man's
sake alone right but at the same time
look at who the prosthetist are mainly
married ex-widows divorcees people with
children people who were divorced people
whose husbands died
and they were alone prostituting them
married them as well
and if you if you if you calculate you
know how many
ex-widows divorcees he or previously
married women he married khadija being
one of them and you compare it to the
amount of women he married who haven't
been married before
personally the only one i know of is
aisha ali literally the only one i know
there could be more allah
but that's the only one i know of um so
subhanallah it's at the same time it's
like
okay i'm gonna be completely honest as a
man when i see like a a muslim woman
who was divorced who doesn't have a
husband anymore
or husband died or she's going through
some rough time it's kind of like
i think about it like you know if i was
capable i would i would have no problem
getting married to her and being there
because women some women do have a
problem obviously
um after going through something like
that uh and that's the son of the
prophet
right that is the sunnah not that
there's anything wrong with marrying for
just because you want to there's nothing
wrong with that just to be clear
but uh and the way the prophet conducted
himself and the way he went about it
is to the benefit of the community and
that's something you see with the
prophet said i'm all throughout his life
right always the the he's being the best
person for the betterment of the
community
um in all aspects of life and i think
that is the the essential message we
need to um
we need to deliver even if it means
being monogamous
even though it means being monogamous
guys i'm i'ma speak
for myself here because i i can't speak
for y'all
but like through my experience with the
women that i've been with
pre-islam and my jahilia days
man like i know what it's like to be
in a relationship where
you lose yourself and like you you give
so much of yourself to this other person
and i'm not saying that's bad uh-huh
all right bro listen i'm not saying
that's bad
but i'm saying like
if they're not with you
bro like it it it destroys you man like
i've been through it twice i've been
through
two times where i was like completely
just hurt bro
one time was cheated on the other time
was just
completely out of nowhere it just
completely stripped away so it's like
for me
to give so much than to have it all just
broken apart it's like
i don't know if it's just me i don't
know if it's just because i'm hurt but
like a part of me
doesn't want to give everything
[Music]
to one person because i know how
imperfect
we are as humans yeah and like i don't
mind giving all of me
to the creator but like to give all of
me to another
human being who is imperfect i've
already seen what happens when i do that
yeah so it's like that's where to me it
just
seems more um logical more rational
to give x amount yes
this one this one and this one let me
let me put in my two cents before romney
goes
uh because i definitely want to hear
romney's point he looks like he has
something very valuable and
relevant right now what i want to say
first and foremost is
alhamdulillah that
every single woman is capable of
cheating on you
just like every single man is capable
of cheating on you every single human
being in this dunya
the way allah has made us because he's
made us with free will we're not angels
will not will but can and has the
ability to cheat
on their spouse yeah what i will say
though
and this might help remedy a little bit
of the
the thing you brought up on her if we
screen girls and not the way like we
screened them in our jahilia days you
know being like
oh i want a girl that looks like this or
i want a girl that does this
nah i'm talking about screen them in the
way of the sunnah where the prophet saws
said
the best women first will be the one who
has
iman right who has taqwa consciousness
of allah who has really high
iman right this girl will be
trust me bro looks money status fame
all of this can be thrown out the window
as in this is the most important thing
right and there's a lot of things that
i rami and angel we can get into in a
bit
where you know we want to talk about red
flags
all right this is going to be in
marriage um or relationships for
our pre-jahilia days but you know we
want to talk about those
and i'm not saying guys that what angel
went through
with one of his his uh experiences what
a lot of people
would go through i'm talking about the
cheating bro and
well a lot of people will go through
that it's gonna we can
completely forbid this from happening no
but what i will i will say
is after romney finishes a point when we
get into the red flags
these can help minimize these so that
the chances of them happening
are so soon to none that it's probably
not gonna happen guys
and we're gonna talk about two things
that you guys could do
first and foremost being things to
screen and look out for
in your spouse right we can mainly only
speak from our experience of looking for
women but i'm sure we can throw on the
thing into about about women
our sisters looking for men but the
second thing we're going to talk about
is what
you got to make sure you keep doing in
your marriage
all right so these two things are we're
going to talk about
it
i love you for the sake of allah man i
love you thank you
um think about it these were non-muslim
women
these are non-muslim women and even you
know you know you know my story and
stuff she
even though she was muslim by name like
come on like in the actions and stuff
she wasn't really there
and uh we both have very similar
experiences unfortunately but think
about it
you know what's better than a woman not
cheating on you
for your sake a woman not cheating on
you for the sake of allah
because there are reasons for you might
die eventually for reasons for allah
if she's at that point you might as well
just leave her like what the hell is the
point of being with her
at that point she doesn't have that that
love for islam that's why the
fossilization the best
traits to look for in a spouse
regardless is good character
and good religion because character you
need someone with good mannerisms
who's nice to you and the scholars talk
about compatibility a lot
masha'allah but when they have the deen
when they have islam when you can just
when you look at them
and you're like this person loves allah
the way i love allah
they love islam the way i love islam and
it's better
that the reason they won't do anything
to harm me is because of allah
because they know they'll be accountable
because if they were to cheat on me
harm me neglect me abuse me manipulate
me
and they don't believe in allah they're
free to do that if they really want to
until i walk away
but if they believe in allah they know
them well that they're going to be
punished for that
and even if it doesn't work out at least
it'll end respectfully
on a good note so yeah when you look at
a woman
if you don't see character in dino
sleeve but if you see character
and you see deen you'll feel the
coolness of your eyes and
and it'll be a lot more comforting in
that moment but this thing we were
operating off of bad experiences in the
past we've never
you know they said like as this i mean
they don't really say it but i say a lot
it's always good till it's bad it's
always bad till it's good right we
always when we're in depressive states
we're like man it's going to be like
this forever until all of a sudden we're
happy we're like damn i'm happy
and then we're happy until it's
something bad happens and it's all of a
sudden i'm bad it literally it takes
just like that because yeah you're so
right bro
how many women do we know that's been
heartbroken by
a man and f boy that they you know they
were just thinking
like a little girl and not like a woman
and they got with and they got tossed
around
in terms of their heart and now they
hear like oh men are trash men are dogs
men are pigs
toxic masculinity this that how many men
do you know
there's been a simp couldn't pick the
right girl
and now they're all like oh these jose
you know there's no good women out here
we gotta all women are evil you're gonna
get cheated on anyway so
let me be celebrated for 90 years bro
yeah come on
there's so many all right all right guys
i understand that 100 but i want to know
if y'all feel
me and where i'm coming from because i'm
not just referring
to cheating i'm referring to a whole
bunch of other things because
again we are imperfect not just the
woman but also the man
and like guys like you're never
going to give 100 to the one because if
you do
well then you're not giving 100 to the
creator yeah
you can only give 100 to one thing so
knowing that you're never going to give
100
to the woman you're going to give her
maybe more than you would anyone else
but it's like
even then the more you give to someone
the more you are allowing them to
basically hurt you and do all this and
i'm not saying this trying to
act from a hurt place or anything i'm
being real i'm being honest
telling you guys from experience like
listen i
i don't i don't share that much
you guys are my friends but do you guys
really know me like how close are we
really
do you know what i mean like me and fire
we went to iceland
and i told him straight up i was like
bro i don't really open up 100
with people i don't tell them everything
i don't let them in
a hundred percent because i know that
once someone's in a hundred percent
like it's just it's too much you know
people are always going to let you down
so it's like
again with all that being said
with knowing that everyone's going to
let you down especially the more
power you give to them the more of your
uh
we'll say time and energy and all this
that you're investing in them
you can never invest 100 but like let's
say the most that you invest into them
the more power they have over doing you
wrong or letting you down
like all right well then it just makes
sense
to have those lives it makes sense to
have four wives where
okay i'm giving y'all a fair amount and
i'm not giving y'all a hundred percent
nor am i being exclusive and giving you
guys
more than you should have where now
you're potentially going to do me dirty
yeah and again like
it sounds now that i'm hearing myself
saying i'm like all right yeah there are
faults
in what i am saying but it's like i am
saying it because
yeah but it's real though it's real
you're not filtering yourself i like
that man
and i see that bro with with how much
soul how much damage can a soul go
through
before it still stays susceptible to
more damage and still stays open
matter of fact in the front lines ready
with open arms for more experiences to
potentially get
damaged and hurt so i could relate to
you well with that 100
first hand but i will say this
at the end of the day what are you going
to do about it bro because and this is
to everyone listening like yay you could
get cheated on but bro
can't i can't on hell can't rami can't
anyone get cheated on
can't someone suck so much can't bro
even abu american bro
if you're tuned in bro yeah you probably
won't
not to disrespect you but you know he's
he's a man so i know he can handle this
you could get cheated on tomorrow you
could get cheated on just like that any
man can get cheated on
why are you going to look at that and be
like oh so now what if i get cheated on
again no
it's what are you going to do about it
so again we're not gonna tell you the
end-all be-all solution but what we are
gonna tell you is what you could do
to minimize that as much as possible so
first i'm gonna hear rami
for men this is just for men your advice
to men
what are the number one things because
first we're going to talk about things
before
the marriage right not maintenance not
how you could keep yourself on point
i'm talking about picking the right girl
what have you got to say bro
all right firstly before i answer that
question i want to i want to comment on
hell said inshallah
so i'm really happy you brought that
point out because that's actually
something i thought of but me being me i
forgot about it so
it is what it is but um i'm glad you
brought it up
uh because i also wanna i also wanna say
that
you said you can't give them all 100 i
agree 100
i agree right no pun intended obviously
but i agree 100
so if you were to give 100 to allah
you know and majority of yourself to
your purpose
right wouldn't that be similar to giving
percentage to this wife that life you
know divided amongst four
like let's let's take the the other wife
of the three other wives and let's
replace it with something
right something a purpose then you're
still only giving her
a certain amount that's why in red pill
they talk a lot about having a purpose
and focusing on yourself because you're
having the same effect as if you had
multiple wives
on the on the woman and she in a way
feels replaceable
and not that that's a good thing but
everybody should know that um including
myself and
the men everybody is replaceable because
as soon as you think
i'm the i'm the hero i'm the spider-man
no one can take over no one can replace
me
that's usually when you get replaced oh
not something bro you're right
yeah but sorry to to answer the question
unless on hell or somebody wanted to
call no no before that i want to
i want to address a point that you made
to address on house point that he made
to address my point
which is going to be that at the end of
the day you got all these men saying oh
should i
text another girl to create attraction
between me and my girl
should i cheat on her to fake high value
it's like bro
why don't you put her second and put
your purpose put a lot put your
career something like that first you
feel me
and it's like that's how you really know
what's real it's not that you know
you're doing things to
you know just being fake and just you
know fake it till you make it now like
you could be all that you want to be but
you got to have something in life that's
bigger than you
first allah and two how are you going to
manipulate and navigate yourself in this
dunya how are you going to position
yourself to be a king
or a queen um but yeah i'ma let you
answer now
just have it and beautifully pause
so let me say this before i forget it
because it's completely
involved all right so think of it like
this you have to give a hundred percent
to the creator because without the
creator you be nothing
right you give 100 to the creator and
everything else
you do for the remembrance of allah
right you work do for the remembrance of
allah you love
you do for the remembrance of allah for
the sake of allah bro
you get married why do you get married
because that
is completing half of the deen
all right bro but it's not in the sense
that you get married and now you're
gonna give
so much to this one person because
that's defeating the purpose
of why you're doing it in the first
place and i'm just gonna go ahead
and chime in and say here that when you
have
multiple wives you are
you basically not letting that occur
because when you only have one woman
it's a lot easier for you to give her
more than
is necessary and the moment you begin to
give her more than is necessary
rami can completely go in on this
and i'm not telling you to say details
because bro
hamdulillah that's done it's over with
it's it is what it is you learn from it
yeah yeah but it's like you can never
give
too much to someone and bro mohammed bro
if you want to have one wife this is i'm
not i'm not
some people some people think that you
guys are knocking
monogamy when you when you like give
benefits of polygamy but it's like nah
like
there's a choice but each has its pros
and
it's cause it just depends on like what
type of person
yeah so whichever one is better for you
yeah with that being said without more
tangents
romney this is the damn question bro yes
all right i just want to say yes 100
you cannot give any any soul too much if
you do that then
it's basically taking too much is
basically i mean there's there's
different standards but basically you
don't want to
get to the point where you take your
worship of allah the place you know
that's designed for allah to be in your
heart and start filling it with someone
else even if it's just one percent
because that's when
you overstep and you mess up and then
usually when you put
something else in the place allah is
supposed to be in your heart he takes it
away he tests you with it
i can say that firsthand and it's just
it is what it is so don't do that
first let me listen hold up hold up i
thought you said no
no i gotta i got a point listen i gotta
finish what i was saying bro
with what with what we were just saying
here
i gotta finish what i was gonna say with
this this is intricate bro this is
intricate girlfriend man i'ma let you go
okay it's very quick
very quick but just to finish all right
it's all about balance and i feel
in my perspective in my humble opinion
that if you have
four wives it's much easier to have the
balance because you are less prone
to giving more to this one person yeah
but again you could have just one wife
and do it you know because if i were to
say no no it's only four wives only four
wives always like okay well now we got
to take in
a whole bunch of other things into
account like well what do you do for
work what is your passion like how much
energy are you giving to that
you know because if i'm if i'm giving so
much to that
then i'm also taking away from my dean
from my creator and stuff like that yeah
y'all understand what i'm saying yeah
yeah
and yo i say this time and time again
but fellas you gotta stop
replacing allah with girls with
women stop using women
as that placeholder to collect
all of your emotional feelings your
heart your
your love your this i'm not saying don't
love a woman and don't
don't be you know don't make them feel
good and don't be emotionally connected
to them but what i'm saying is
that little voice in your in your head
that little feminine energy that you got
because obviously as men we still got
that that tells you you know
i need this thing this this this place
of contact that i can collect my love
that i could just pour my heart out that
i could just share everything about my
day
that i could just give my soul to fully
why are you doing that to your women
when
your woman when women can't even take
that the right way when they don't even
know how to handle that bro
you might scare her off you might at the
end of the day look
women do that to us to men they vent to
you they come home to tell you oh
this is what happened at work see they
do this because at the end of it
they feel that relief they feel good
they feel like okay i just let i just
discharged all this energy that i had
and they feel more connected to you but
it's not the same way with with women
fellas if you go to your woman
and you tell her about this you vent you
do this bro it's not the same
what you should be doing is do this to
the most high to allah to the source
you should be on the prayer mat
on your knees hearing i don't care if
you're crying if you're breaking down
repenting venting showing all your
frustrations
sharing everything crying for help
crying for guidance crying for
the blessings of allah and it's like at
the end of the day
this is the point allah is the point of
contact that you need to be letting all
of this out on
because at the end of the day i
guarantee you that feeling that a woman
has when she's done venting to her man
is going to be the feeling that you have
when you're done opening up to allah
on the name the salah and when you've
done that and when you're done that
you can truly feel good and non-needy
and non-emotionally like i need to give
this to my woman
when you talk to her you're going to go
to her you're going to be more grounded
you're going to be more cool you're
going to be more chill
and she'll sense that from you you know
what i mean and it's like
part of it knows damn like why can't why
can't i be that but it's like trust me
like women women say that but
they don't want that so at the end they
put allah first
make allah the thing that women look to
you as
obviously women should look to allah
before they're mad but you guys get what
i'm what i'm saying for the sake of
scenario
the thing that women need you as to be
that rock to be that thing that
they can be a storm around you gotta
look at allah
to be that so that you can be yourself
and fully let go emotionally around
yeah and there's nothing wrong with that
because allah tells you time and time
again my slave come to me repent to me
pour your heart out to me share
everything with me
so why don't you start having that that
scenario because girls are really good
at that man girls have
they have diaries bro they got the
sisterhood they got the friends on speed
dial
their bro they know that we're open
energy systems like on halloween
preachers and they know that they can
discharge any time
but as men we we constantly try to
repress ourselves because like
okay yeah i'll admit it bro no other man
wants to hear your issues we're not like
girls
but it's like allah is always there 24
7. here's the thing
you wanna you wanna hit up your homies
it's 5 a.m and you're like damn bro
they're asleep i know you guys know that
feeling
you can relate to that and you're like
damn how could i hit them up if they're
they're catching some sleep oh i gotta
wait till tomorrow so you cry yourself
to sleep or
i don't know bro some guys are hell
emotional but it's like allah is open
it's 5 a.m fajr is an hour away you
could pray to hajj you could do the
night prayer
and you could pray to allah allah is
never going to close his doors for you
so why don't you use that yeah man bro
so romney before you say something
because i i feel it i feel it coming
from you right now
um i
went through a period in my where life
i try to be more open and just like talk
about
my uh feelings and emotions
bro that does not work let me tell you
something
as a man there's a reason why we try to
hold everything in
because one when we're over here trying
to talk to everyone about it like
it doesn't really do the same thing that
it does for a woman
that it does for us but two
we can't fully handle it on ourselves or
by ourselves and that's where the
creator comes in
you know i'll open up a little bit here
with y'all and say that last night
or for the past for the past like three
weeks
i've been feeling real low
i've been feeling real low about a lot
of things but i didn't tell
anyone bro no one close to me did i tell
them did i share
this negative feeling that i was feeling
because one i knew was temporary and two
why would i want to bring someone down
with something that i'm experiencing i
just want to lift other people up
all right so i dealt with that i went
into prayer bro
and like dude i just broke down
in prayer praying to allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
and that to me was
the most relief that i've
ever experienced before because like you
know i haven't been muslim my entire
life like
i'm still new to this but like me doing
that
me being in prayer like you said you do
the prayer
you go to the creator you don't go to
anyone else you go to the creator
and you release to the creator bro
that's that's next level
and you actually feel like you have more
energy after don't you bro
yeah when we go to our homies
we don't feel that discharge bro we're
like damn bro let me go to another homie
well now let me tell this person let me
tell my mom
it's like when you go to allah you truly
feel done yeah
bro and it's it's weird because like
when i would go to my friends in the
past i felt exactly what you said
was like i don't feel that full release
maybe i need to talk about it some more
maybe i need to talk to my other friend
over here he's more into this stuff
he's more like uh more wiser and has
more knowledge and can really help me
out with these things
but man i'm being i'm being 100 my bad
i'm being 100 honest here and saying
like
whenever i would tell my friends that
bro
i would feel weak because i know i i
knew
that subconsciously a part of them was
judging me
and basically seeing me as a weaker
version you know because i'm i'm
literally like
stepping down and being vulnerable to
this person but this person is not god
this person is not the creator
this person can't solve my issues this
person is just here listening to what
i'm saying
and by me doing that i feel weak and
this
bro like it never gave me the release
that i wanted
and it it almost made it worse
it almost broke like the feeling that i
had it almost
made it worse and it's like i felt even
weaker and once i did it to allah
once i just stepped down and just
released it all to a lot it's like
there was no feeling of weakness there
was no feeling of judgment there was
just
it was almost like everything that i had
was just fully stripped away
and nothing but strength was given
nothing but clarity was given
nothing but peace was given bro and
that's
that's next level bro guys you can you
can't compare this to anything else
um and before we listen listen for the
sake of just
staying on topic because i know we're
too raw and too unfiltered i'ma let
romney answer the question that i
originally asked how do we stop this but
i
under 100 can acknowledge and relate to
you
bro angel because at the end of the day
women and this is this is game for for
fellas too
when your woman is coming to you and
wants to vent stop being there like how
do i fix her problems
how do i how do i you know solve her her
issues she's coming at me with this
and i'm gonna be too analytical bro
sometimes you get too caught up in
trying to fix your woman's problems that
you're not even listening to your woman
some some people and i'd say most women
don't really need you
to vent to so you give them clear-cut
advice they just need something to let
their heart out onto
and just share their feelings with so at
the end of the day hear them up first
yeah
here and there throw your advice but bro
some people more people than not
and i'm talking about men i know in my
life too they just want someone to talk
to
so just hear them up bro and that's the
thing with romney like i know this is
about romney whenever i'm telling him
something like
i don't really vent him but if i'm
sharing something with him or if i had
had a good day or i i tell him anything
bro this man waits till i'm done talking
and it's like at the end of that that's
already a release he's not here like oh
how do i solve this guy's problems how
do i be a guidance counselor he's not
out here trying to do that he's just
here like
okay cool i appreciate that man thank
you for sharing that sometimes bro
that's enough
but i'm gonna let you answer now what
can men do in the modern day
to screen and make sure that only the
best or as up american says vetting
because vetting is essentially just
screening out the bad women
how can men do that today what can they
look out for
okay so firstly
so i mentioned before character indeen
right so with things that matter to you
as an individual
you have to know where you draw the line
and what things you can tolerate so
let's say for example
you do not want a woman and you can even
like literally make a list
make a list you should make a list of
the men you want to be and the woman you
want to have or the women you want to
have
if you have if you draw the line of i do
not want her talking to men
maybe at work okay school once in a
while if she needs to if it's necessary
okay but i don't want her being friends
with men
make that a priority and if you see
she's friends with men
by literally that easy a lot of people
are scared to say bye
bro where'd you get all that game from
i know some brothers masha allah i'ma
just say
you need to know what you want you need
to make it clear right
and you need to know where maybe you can
you can tolerate a little bit right
and that differs from person to person
but essentially
with character you want to see who she
is a lot of time
if i had mentioned we're very analytical
we're very logical rational thinking
about
analyzing things right but the issue is
a lot of the time we're analyzing the
wrong thing we're analyzing
what she's saying not how she's saying
it
because sometimes how someone says
something is more important than what
they're saying words can be meaningless
but the powers behind how they're saying
it what they mean when they say it
right so
you have to analyze how they're saying
the things they're saying of course what
they're saying but how they're saying it
the words they're using the tone they
have the way they express themselves
and you have to kind of drawing a blank
here
um oh yeah also you have to watch how
they move who they are even you have to
do a little bit of social media stalking
you know see the friends there with see
how they treat their family
mannerisms character and think
as soon as you bro be a little bit
critical right go with two eyes open
i heard this saying once when you're
when you're looking for someone for
marriage go with two eyes open
once you're in marriage shut one eye
right keep one eye open keep one eye
shot you don't want to be too critical
in marriage but when you're vetting
this is game time filter you put the
brita filter on
filter out the not the stuff right so
watch them if you see something you
don't have to confront them
take note of it notice it if it's a
continual pattern
an issue buy call us by on to the next
as one brother once told me you missed
you missed the bus you catch the next
one 15 minutes later
all right i wonder i wonder who said
that it's kind of long
but anyways anyways it's literally that
simple like
looking for marriage is not marriage
until you're in
you don't owe anybody anything you could
be talking for a few months all of a
sudden you wanna you see something bad
you go some peace it is what it is
that's the character sign next is the
dean because not wanting someone
not wanting your wife or your your
future wife to
talk to other guys is not just the
character um
preference it's an islamic thing as well
so now it ties into deen so you have to
look how are they acting in terms of
their deen
how is even things like their hijab i'm
not saying you shouldn't marry someone
because their hijab's a little off
but you have to notice these things and
if you pair her lack of hijab with maybe
her lack of modesty when she's speaking
to people
you put two and two together maybe her
modesty isn't there
and modesty is a big part of iman a big
part of faith maybe she's not praying
her prayers i i honestly think if a
woman doesn't pray is tahara
if a woman does not pray is tahara for
marriage that's that's a bad sign it's
takara is basically
when you pray to raqqa you ask you make
god to allah if this is good for me make
it so
if not take it away from me if she
doesn't do that that's worrisome
is basically like for marriage that's
what people use it for nowadays it's for
everything
but nowadays mainly when it comes up
it's like for marriage or something
that's
one of the big decisions so character if
you see things you don't like
you walk away right if you see things
you like
you stay you keep going you see who they
are the person look at their dean
look at their family a lot of this is
the big one a big one a lot of the time
people think she's amazing
even though her father is horrible her
mom is a vile
back you know back biter her siblings
are mentally deranged
she's good which family you're marrying
into
you're gonna you're gonna have to deal
with that you have to deal with the mom
and the dad and the family
look at the family so that's what i
would say those are the big three
character special level religion on
special level
and family look at those things but yeah
when you talk brother
that's gold before you start your next
point um my phone's about to die so i
might
end up leaving early no worries bro no
worries
all right listen it's been a pleasure
having you if it dies it does
if it doesn't it doesn't if you want to
leave right now cool but
thank you so much bro from the bottom of
our hearts for all you do
welcome to the team for t3m we are
looking forward to
having you contribute more to the
podcast and just growing with us
yeah i wasn't looking forward to
crossing you up dunking on you
and yeah but i wasn't talking much
because i had so much to learn from this
so yeah i was just paying attention
the whole time oh man always man
all right so my point being is
the three things that you said bro thank
you so much for sharing that rami
i will say something very similar his
character and integrity thing
number one bro if you got a girl who's
saying one thing but her actions are
showing something else
cut that off right away yeah and this
could be something like a little lie
bro i don't tolerate lies here's the
thing if she tells you something that's
like a white lie like
you know trying to be nice like here's
the thing there's a difference between
that and her just
being a compulsive liar even if it's
little things so i notice these things
i'm cognizant of these things best
believe so
these are things when she says one thing
but her actions show something else
i don't want that number two if she's
masculine bro it's a wrap just for me
like me i can't speak on behalf of the
choir but i will say
i am naturally someone that likes to
lead and i'm a good leader type so for
me i need a good follower type
um and at the end of the day rami
already said it best the prophet saws
said that good company is better than
loneliness but loneliness is better than
bad company
so what makes you think i'd rather not
be lonely than be with a masculine girl
i wouldn't so at the end of the day
i would i would put 100 a feminine girl
that's okay to be feminine
and she's worked through this media
programming and social conditioning
that tells you oh being feminine is bad
you're being weak
you shouldn't do this bro that's just
capitalism man that's capitalism for you
telling you that a woman
submitting to her boss and her her
corporation is better than a man
submitting to her husband come on now
that can't be that can't be straight um
i would say another point would be
a girl that is always punctual if a girl
is on time and this is for anyone in
general
punctuality is a huge thing this is a
reminder to myself too but
a girl that's always on time she's
always there she stays
true to her word this is key number four
this is just me personally the thing
that romney said too this was for him
too personally
the no male friend thing this is this is
for me this is 100
it this is not some insecurity you're
like
oh i don't like if you text this guy
uh you know i feel like you're gonna
start forming nah bro
for me it's more so like wow that's just
that's just a boundary for me
i don't want to deal with that it's it's
from the sunnah it's from islam
it's from it's from the prophet saws
ways and it's like bro at the end of the
day
why why i'm not doing that like you feel
me like i'm not here texting chicks
behind my
behind your back and doing doing
something so it's not necessary
now here's the thing yeah i get it if
you gotta text your co-worker or you got
because a lot of guys hit me up they're
like
oh um my girlfriend uh you know
have has this co-worker and you know
she needs to text him to like trade
shifts and coordinate
the the opening schedules and all that
i'm like
okay why she got him on snapchat though
man
you know what i mean like you don't need
snapchat to trade ships bro like let's
let's be honest now
so things like that look out for and i
want to address the point that rami said
two this is very important
rami said the thing about her family
here's the thing bro you cannot control
her family
but you are marrying you know
in not into their family but it's like
they're gonna be there
to some degree so i'm not going to fully
say what rami said is 100
but i'm not going to say zero percent
either i will agree
with rami's point that be aware and
conscious of the family
know that the things that they do
toxic family members these are things
that i'm not going to say the girl has
but the things that the girl had growing
up
whether she builds up her life to the
point where she
overcomes those things and works through
them and lets that dead baggage go
that's a different story if she does
call us subhanallah
marry her but if she doesn't be aware of
that and if these things keep coming up
remember that birds of a feather flock
together but i'm not going to say this
is true for every single case this is
true
on average right it's a generalization
because it's true it's cliche
um the last thing i want to know and
this is just for me
is here's the thing bro
you want a girl just like khadija
radiola just like angel said who is your
backbone
she's not going to be someone who wants
to count favors
you want someone that fully gives in to
your agenda
if you tell her hey babe this is my
purpose this is my life this is my
whatever school this is my mission this
is my
uh this is my craft and here's how you
can help me or she should be wanting to
help you anyway
that's a keeper bro it's not a girl
who's gonna remember what she did five
days ago and
oh i did the dishes yesterday so today
you're gonna do the dishes no bro
and bro that's really real men notice
these things like things when
a girl really does things without
counting favors
it's not that we forget these things but
we notice these things and we like these
things
so at the end of the day this is some of
the things that i think
should be uh things that you screen out
for this is pre-marriage because we're
gonna talk about post marriage after
but if you want the whole you want the
whole nine yards of the game consider
getting on patreon because come on now
this is just youtube
let us hear your two cents the formula
yes so
let me just say that um i think i have
like five percent
battery so we're gonna have to cut this
short
but to finish off i think this is all
beautiful
one thing that i would add in that's
super important and guys get it twisted
all the time
is chemistry i'm not talking about
legitimate science i'm talking about
like
the chemistry that you experience with a
woman and this
not just looks looks is a big part
of the chemistry but i'm also speaking
of in terms of um
i i wish there were studies for this but
i'm just gonna like
i'm gonna put myself out here i'ma
proclaim this theory
so if y'all wanna accept it you can
accept it if you don't wanna accept it
don't accept it that's cool
but the pheromones the pheromones that
we release
and yes we as humans do release
pheromones because if you go into
these stores that have the colognes the
perfumes you could have the same scent
put on your skin and that same scent
put on ramy skin is gonna smell
different
on him than it does on me why is this
because of our
pheromones the way that it all interacts
the chemistry
so your pheromones have to intertwine
and mix with her pheromones and if like
let's say you meet the girl
and it's like yo you think she's super
attractive her judgment of character is
on
point where it's like everything she
passes all the tests
and her dean is on point but you know
what
the chemistry's just not there
and i feel like if if one were to
disregard that
and say ah well everything else is good
so i'm just gonna go ahead and uh
shoot shoot the shot here i'm just gonna
get married with her like that's
that's a huge downfall yeah
yeah represent man i like where you're
going with that and bro
romney if you have a quick point i'm
gonna let you speak but if that's it for
pre bro i know you have five percent or
less imma just hear you go straight into
things
in the maintenance of your marriage
things that men that fellows can do
after getting married
i'm not married so i can't really okay i
can't
give you much advice for your pre-jahlia
days ah
after the girl bro come on one thing one
thing
masculine frame you always have to have
the masculine frame what does this mean
it means exactly what it implies meaning
that the masculine frame is you
being in your masculine being the man in
the relationship
and the woman being in her feminine
frame being the feminine
the woman in the relationship if that
switches
and you go into your feminine and the
woman goes into her masculine
it's only a matter of time before it all
falls apart
big facts bro i would just say to add to
that point that
guys so many guys i know after they get
into a relationship
their bank balance looks worse than
before
the relationship so many guys i know
after before marriage
they look lost yeah after the marriage
they they look worse and it's like bro
why would she not lose attraction for
you
at the end of the day if she found you
when you're let's say an eight out of
ten
if you stay at an eight out of ten do
you realize she has nothing to lose
she's still gonna be constantly
attracted to you if you increase
and you keep improving yourself bro
she's only going to get more and more
attracted to you because however much
she was attracted to before
you're more improved now so if you had
100
in your bank now you got 100k oh she's
more attracted if you look like
a six out of ten before now you're not
outside ah she's more attracted to you
if you had no purpose in life now you
got you're doing something for the world
and you're trying to
change the whole dunya ah she's gonna be
more attracted to you so my advice to
you
is at the very least
be who you were when you signed up
throughout the whole terms of the
agreement
worst case scenario i'm just saying this
is going to be it under no circumstance
will you
depreciate will you regress when you
decline
over the course of your marriage the
best case scenario you're going to
improve
obviously because again we're not trying
to raise boys here we're trying to raise
men
who are actually going to empower
themselves and stay
in the masculine like arnold said not
guys who fall for those tests like when
the girl says
oh you can do this it's okay i'm not
gonna look at you some other way like
bro come on
the other day i heard that one too many
times from past
experiences with past girls so at the
end of the day bro to keep it simple
be who you are man don't lose yourself
in the journey and i would say the
second most important thing because
i said one this is my first point my
second and last point for
maintaining your marriage and you know i
would say
bro this is key transparency
all right transparency i'm not going to
say some cliche thing like communication
but it's true
how many times bro on him picture this
bro you got a wife
you got two kids all right your kids
want to do something
that you wouldn't be okay with what do
you tell them
no here's the thing though they know
that so they go to
their mom they go to your wife your wife
knowing that you won't approve that
lets them do it because she would be
okay with them doing it oh that's
disrespect
100 the only way that the woman would
disrespect you is if you're not in your
masculine frame
100 at the end of the day bro i don't
care if you seen your mama do that this
is for the women
i don't care if you've seen your your
sister do that your cousins do that
your grandmama do that that's not how we
run things over here
so at the end of the day i don't care if
you know you're okay with that at the
end of the day
this is not some like you know male
supremacy thing like i'm running things
even though that's kind of the dynamic
it has to be
and provided that at the end of the day
the least you could do is be
transparent right so if your wife came
to you at the least
and said hey your kids want to do this
you know they're thinking of doing this
wouldn't you look at her with so much
more respect and be close to her than
her just
allowing them to do it and then you
finding out later
from external sources not even from her
the kids
like bro just think about that bro at
the end of the day transparency is
something that
couples lack today yeah but it all
starts and my bad rami i want you to go
but the last thing i just want to slide
in here
is that it all starts with the masculine
frame
because if you're not in your masculine
and she doesn't see you as
daddy for lack of better words bro
she's not going to be transparent with
you and
she's not what was the other thing you
said fired communication
communication was it communication i
said transparency most of the time
you said transparency for your second
thing what was the first thing that you
mentioned
don't lose yourself don't get lost in
the sauce
but would you get lost in the sauce if
you were being daddy
i don't know if you were being the man
in the relationship
you wouldn't so it's like it all stems
back to
you being a proper man
in the relationship yeah at least
and i'ma say something right now and i
feel like rami will definitely say this
at this point because rami always says
this
you should be doing this for you not for
the woman
so yeah i'm gonna let you speaking
around me
uh i just i wanted to say this for a
while so i want to get it in now
insha'allah
i'm not gonna use the term submit to the
husband
but a woman and i want i want everyone
to listen
a woman being submissive right a woman
being submissive to her husband
is a part of her submitting to allah
i'll say it again
a woman being submissive to her husband
is a part of her submitting to allah
one the way allah created the woman to
be naturally submissive and two
her not obeying because obey has a bad
connotation
but i'll say listening to the husband
and the things that he is obligated in
for example protecting her right it's
normal
it's natural it's healthy for a woman to
be submissive to her husband and it's
normal naturally
natural and healthy for the man to be
dominant that's just how it's been
for like ever forever everything done
from psychology to biology to islam to
everything
says this so a woman being submissive
to her husband is not demeaning it's
maximizing
and it's her listening and being in
submitting to allah alone
that's essentially what i wanted to say
i also wanted to plug in
um [ __ ] american and gabriel el romani
uh we had them both as you know uh
honorable guests mashallah in the past
um their work is like amazing just you
know listen to their stuff by their
books and and
uh there are people i look up to that's
why i'm recommending them
uh because they go back to quran and
sunnah and
uh they yeah their their work is great
masha'allah that's basically it from me
mum is a woman i mean yo you have
something to say before your one percent
goes to zero
now let's end it here guys good part is
i was gonna say it's fine all right
so yo eben the time traveler has entered
the waiting room
why don't we let him
let him set his stuff mm-hmm
there yeah i can hear you guys now
just like that bro we were literally
just gonna wrap it up right now
all right i'm back for that let's see
i got these broken glasses got the glass
oh yikes what happened
[Music]
oh i just stepped on them bro you better
not wear those when i'm balling you up
bro
trust bro i hoop better without my
glasses
well you better have some contacts on
all right when angel said balling you up
what did what did you think he meant
because
did the same thing pop in your head that
popped in my head when he said balling
up yeah
is that toronto slaying bro yeah yeah
what does it mean
[Music]
oh we know you're not talking about that
bro yeah
you got that purple jacket bro not that
purple rosemary but
for the sake of our first time ever this
is not a feature guys like
this is our actual legitimate first time
speaking to muhammad too
so for the sake of that bro we're going
to let you end it off today
oh me yeah man hey before you end it off
if anyone made it this far go ahead and
put hashtag
break your ankles i was gonna say broken
glasses man it's perfect it's right it's
broken okay broken glasses broken glass
that's actually very shitty
broken on hell yeah damn
i am broken i am broke
this man putting me on blast give your
give your thoughts
just to the viewers that made it this
far it could be anything man
um just give it a like
give it a share push this podcast
out there that's all i have to say i
don't have much to say
and i want rami to end it off like usual
100
of them amy all
there you go there it is
[Music]
[Music]